every time you find yourself here it's
because you chose to come back
[Music]
hello my name is Mark s
[Music]
and I have of my own free Accord elected
to undergo the procedure known as
severance
I give consent to sever my memories
between my work life
and my personal life
I acknowledge that once the procedure is
complete I will be unable to access my
personal memories whilst on the severed
floor say gratitude nor will I retain
work memories hey
sorry when I return home
at the end of the day
[Music]
I make these statements freely
hi kids what's for dinner we warned you
about the greeting you were kidding we
hate it how many reasons did we come up
with eight good morning hi Mr milcheck
Mark could I have a word PD is no longer
with this company I'm sorry Mark you
guys are one of my favorite office
friendships what happened we'd love to
tell you but unfortunately
non-disclosure policy forbids I confer
upon you the advanced role of Department
chief congratulations a handshake is
available upon request
thank you may I have a handshake
do I know you my name is Petey I'm from
work
so we're friends I'm your best friend
nothing
is what they say
I used to think it would take a monster
to put someone in a place like that
office
especially if the person was himself
if you want to know what's going on down
there
you'll find the beginning
a very long answer
it's happening
what is it we actually do here
it's important your eyes be kind do you
know how to make your eyes kind
[Music]
of